good morning believe nation today's
message is there is no overnight success
over to Tory Burch being an entrepreneur
isn't just a job title it isn't just
about starting a company it's about a
state of mind it's about seeing
connections others can't seizing
opportunities others won't and forging
new directions that others haven't it's
about being entrepreneurial wherever you
are and in whatever you do it's about
having the courage to give into a
passion for an idea that makes your
heart race and if it doesn't scare you
the idea isn't big enough here's what
I've learned we may live in an age of
instant messaging instant gratification
and Instagram but there is no way to
short-circuit the path to success it
takes hard work tenacity and a lot of
patience there are many things you can
do overnight you can write a decent
paper you can put finishing touches on a
fashion show I hear you can even have a
pretty good time at Rogers pub but there
is no such thing as an overnight success
it is a myth that glosses over what
being an entrepreneur is all about as
biz stone one of the founders of
Twitter's put it timing perseverance and
10 years of really hard work will
eventually make you look like an
overnight success so the question today
for you guys is do you believe that
overnight success is a myth leave in the
comments below I'll join the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events festival
this recipe Viggo